NOW IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
TAT-SCREWED.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
SOMETIMES TATTOOS ARE LIKE
GOLD MEDALS IN THE BAD DECISION
OLYMPICS BECAUSE WHEN LIFE HANDS
YOU LEMONS WHY NOT MAKE TOO MUCH
MIKE'S HARD LEMONADE AND LET A
RETIRED BMX BIKER (BLEEP) ON
YOUR SKIN WITH A TATTOO GUN.
THE CAPPER? WHEN YOU SHARE THAT
BAD DECISION ON THE INTERNET.
I WILL DESCRIBE TWO TERRIBLE
TATTOOS AND FOR 250 POINTS YOU
TELL MEWHICH ONE IS REAL.
FIRST UP --
A HAND TATTOOED MICKEY MOUSE'S
HAND OR A FOOT TATTOOED
LIKE AN AIR JORDAN.
STEPHEN.
>> I THINK IT HAS TO BE THE HAND
TATTOOED LIKE MICKEY MOUSE'S
HAND.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
NOPE.
>> WOW.
>> Chris: NOW THE LOGISTICAL
PROBLEM WITH THIS TATTOO IS THE
SHOE IS TOO SMALL.
IT'S JUST TOO SMALL.
>> DO YOU THINK HE GOES TO THE
BASKETBALL COURT AND HE IS LIKE,
YO, GUYS, CHECK OUT MY NEW JS.
>> Chris: THOSE ARE YOUR
DISGUSTING FEET.
>> NO, MAN, I JUMP HIGHER.
>> Chris: NO, YOU JUST BROKE ALL
OF YOUR TOES.
>> NO MAN, IT'S THE SHOES.
>> THAT'S AWFUL.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE --
A MICHAEL JACKSON TATTOO THAT
SAYS HE TOUCHED SO MANY.
OR -- YOU GUYS ARE SICK.
OR RANDY JACKSON TATTOO THAT
SAYS DAWGY STYLE.
LENNY.
>> PLEASE, PLEASE BE MICHAEL
JACKSON'S TATTOO.
>> Chris: SHOW ME THE MAN IN
THE MIRROR!
THERE IT IS.
>> THE GREAT THING IS IF HE GETS
A REALLY, REALLY GOOD TAN HE
GOES BACK TO THE OTHER MICHAEL
JACKSON.
>> IT IS POETIC.
>> Chris: FINALLY AMERICA'S
WORST TATTOO BROUGHT US WHICH OF
THE FOLLOWING: A VOMITTING
SHRIMP OR A SUICIDAL HOT DOG.
TOBOLOWSKY.
>> GOTTA BE THE SUICIDAL HOT
DOG.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
SUICIDAL HOT DOG!
>> YES.
>> WELL DONE, WELL DONE.
>> IT'S GOTTA BE, IT'S GOTTA BE.
>> YEAH, YEAH.